contemplation is like the silence in the
eye
of the storm
you start to fade you have no strong
roots to this world
you are losing touch with yourself
you must purify yourself regain your
equilibrium
i can help you sit down
okay i'm listening
[Music]
in the city you are cut off from nature
metal concrete canyons neon eyes
the filth of the world suffocates you
sure isn't no zen garden you must become
still restore the bond within yourself
you are the source all what you must do
is draw from it are you ready
i'll give it a shot why not i will give
you a meditative brain dance
that will liberate your consciousness
give me you can pay me however much you
wish
this should cut it very well
the initial techniques of meditation are
best undertaken with supervision
let us begin i will guide you
[Music]
this is a meditation of the earth
element
spirit of nature mother earth i send you
greetings we are of one blood
i am you you are me
o mother earth i and all other creatures
from you created cleanse my body
and soul from pain sickness impurity
and the negative energy from negative
people
worlds and dimensions give me the energy
of life
give me health youth wisdom
knowledge strength joy
happiness and inner peace
we walk the earth through meadows nature
in full bloom
we remove our shoes feel our bare feet
touch the soil
we absorb the earth's energy
we sense joy tranquility lightness
purity our heart and soul
we walk the earth a butterfly rests on
blooming flower
bees are gathering nectar warmth and joy
surrounds us our legs absorb the earth's
energy
filling every cell of our bodies our
souls and spirits are cleansed
we thank you mother earth with our mind
body and soul there is no life without
you
or the other elements
what's um uh
hello nice vanishing trick
ah [ __ ]